[Music]
we're about to talk about the craft
we are about to talk about the craft and
here's why
I want to bring up a couple things
before I hit play
bro what the [ __ ] happened to Dane
Cook's face
what the [ __ ] happened I think he was
drinking a lot in San Jose I was talking
this comic okay I'm so sorry I have
apologized
but Brendan is dressed like the old lady
that used to watch me in recess after
school like no seriously look everything
about him look look everything about him
is dressed like a Hispanic lady that
would be taking care of kids what are
you doing Brendan
Brendan Abuelita exactly
and uh he was like yeah I sold out my
you look like a gringo Mommy
first weekend added shows I'm like how
long you been doing these all three
years I'm like Jesus Christ and I go
what soda did a clip man minute 30 clip
like the men just went viral I'm like
holy [ __ ] that's a career I'd be can I
ask why Callan is wearing a shirt that's
made out of the suicide vest that they
give you in jail
this is it was a Keepsake from his dad's
old CIA job
that's [ __ ] ing
this one this whole layout this one
belonged to Khalid Sheikh Muhammad
um that is the Virgie you're right it
would be a CIA a CIA Planet Hollywood
where they had terrorists or like
Muhammad atta's passports behind glass
yeah man this is Osama Bin Laden's porno
collection
awesome this was Saddam Hussein's n64.
um no but seriously Virgie back me up
here is that not the same
pattern like that looks like the when
they give you the turtle vest in jail
like when they don't trust you to not
hurt yourself the [ __ ] are you have
you have on this are you trying to
try to look you know enough about it you
know enough I'm just [ __ ] with you
yeah it looks exactly like it you've had
enough you've looked up pictures of
enough garbage people that you grew up
with and we're close with yeah every
once in a while and seeing the mug shots
I'm sorry I'm just so [ __ ] distracted
by acid attack victim Dane Cook bro his
face is bad and it's like you would
think of like grooming a girl at a board
board game night would like make you
look younger but apparently no it
doesn't
it does look like it's [ __ ] like he
does look like you know the meme looks
like a grown-up version of the meme of
the kid that's like with like the vein
on his forehead that's like you know the
vegan thing that they can't when it's
always exploding ready to say something
fascinated to like watch because yeah
his face is tricky you know when you his
face like all you could see tell like
where he had worked on
all around his hairline and his face it
looks like [ __ ] Peter Weller and
RoboCop
oh I can't unsee it oh my God you nailed
it
yeah yeah
oh with the helmet off someone holy holy
[ __ ] RoboCop I got it I got you there uh
robo
cop by the way I actually
um was cool like I liked Dane Cook I
always thought he was funny growing up
um
and uh you know so he's he was always a
nice guy even when he was like a younger
comic you nailed it bro
[ __ ] that's all he's ever gonna be to me
now hold on hold on
there it is there it is
you just tell he got a lot of work done
but they oh
oh [ __ ] Dead or Alive you're coming with
me that's him talking to the 17 year old
[Laughter]
two minute 44 second clip I'm calling it
it's gonna be the last clip of the show
watch of course there's no way we get
through the rest of this you get like
invited into the Inner Circle usually
what normally would happen is you get
there you know based on maybe like One
Shining Moment I believe that Boston
exists first off trust me I know Boston
exists because every time someone from
Boston is around they never shut the
[ __ ] up and secondly Barbie doll hair
what's going on with the bad plugs bro
that's Barbie doll hair bed plugs and
also why do you have acne scars when I
don't recall you ever having acne no or
acne scars he he always has no no no no
hold on hold on he always has his face
got bigger and when he pulled his skin
back it made them more apparent
you know what I mean
Dane Cook now looks like the result of
zigfried and Roy shaking up their sperm
in a test tube and [ __ ] injecting it
through
yeah
with with the with the tiger with the
tiger face scars and everything but then
they're in the what else do you got
business yeah and so to break through
that rapidly and to be able to fill the
room I want to know like but but I think
I think that because we're in an excerpt
world that and I this is even like front
and center of my new special it's even
more nice plug important so far 33
people have seen it there can be no
garbage talk there really can't be any
[ __ ] Flotsam and Jetsam you gotta put
real truth into whatever it is that
you're putting out there you have to
speak truth to power I've been saying
that like if you read my book called
It's called speaking truth to power a
good guide
true it's it's called comedy it's not
called Truth telling it's called comedy
comedy it's called comedy look like like
I said before like when the greats like
Carlton are out there you know
because I think that's what Hooks people
into wanting to watch the next clip of
you if they're getting something no you
know what Hooks people to watch the next
clip of Brendan is you wonder can he be
stupider than before and you know what
he most certainly can you know anytime a
new Brendan clip pops up people just go
what did he [ __ ] up there we go
something really real as well as
something really funny whenever
Brendan's not around people should be
asking where's Brendan own and operate
your own material in a in a world where
like you're doing you're creating your
own network already why pass it off
looks like I just bought a Link cable
and traded one of the boganoff twins to
my little brother on Pokemon Red
person or people that are going to then
third-party it whether they say they are
or not
those fingers are going to go out and
they're going to receive plugs really
are big they're bad they're bad plugs
um and then the monetization that they
received you probably won't even know
about and then you're gonna sit and wait
for maybe a year or two for your
residual checks and why are they going
to hold it well didn't your brother like
steal your money Dane if I remember
correctly it was that's right yeah his
brother like stole like a lot of his
money because they're making the
interest of your money holding it and
you'll end up chasing chasing I've had
bad record deals that I'm still in
breach of contract uh negotiations to to
get back what I made what I but like how
did somebody I think about this like
Dane Cook was the biggest person on the
planet and self-made self-made mud
leverage the mice made himself on
MySpace became the biggest known thing
everybody was talking about them but how
come he didn't have the same like
staying power as like somebody like a
Louis CK or a Chappelle or they're still
around and they're still [ __ ] doing
it like nobody talks about Dane Cook's
new special he might still be funny I
don't know I'm not judging his stand-up
I haven't really seen his new stand-up
he could still be hilarious but
he just disappeared I honestly just
think I don't think anybody
I don't the problem with Dean Cook is
that I think his albums and his DVDs and
his specials were doing like
Mega Mega Money like they were doing
crazy numbers
um and I think that people want to cash
in and they saw him as a leading man and
then he had a couple movies and he like
employed a month did okay uh good luck
Chuck did okay and then all his other
movies flopped and he I don't just think
I think eventually they go man we lost a
lot of money on this guy I'm not putting
him in another you know right right I
think you fall out of favor and I think
he fell out of favor because you know
they probably didn't recoup all the
money they made on those later movies I
played the month probably five dollars I
couldn't have made that much money no it
did it did actually pretty well did it
really it didn't do it it didn't do like
they weren't [ __ ] pulling up a Brinks
truck or anything but it made well
that's right the Andy Dick push
to add to what you were just saying if
he was saying he's in breach of contract
on albums and [ __ ] then he's under
contract for comedy albums he probably
couldn't go back to recording albums
after the movie [ __ ] maybe crazy that's
what I was gonna say was there something
that happened were you like all right
I'm not going the traditional route
anymore I'm going to do this it was
probably a a mixture of some bad deals
along the way but also realizing from my
career early like when I was selling
these through my first website he got
[ __ ] on his uh on his uh his comedy
albums right there okay because he
signed his comedy out I guarantee what
happened was he signed his comedy albums
when he was still young and didn't have
a lawyer there are so many people that
get [ __ ] by one I wonder who that
record I wonder I wonder if that's
another Kanye situation huh I was owning
and operating the whole day I was a
fulfillment center I was and it was more
gratifying I like what I'm doing right
now I love this more than any other
opportunity to do two or three or do you
want a package or do you want to no I'd
rather just in real time be able to
watch and see where in the world my fans
are enjoying my stand-up so that I can
better Target what I want to do next
what are you doing though I don't know
what you're doing hanging out with with
the with shop